Hola Bienvenidos a una semana en el
mundo el programa de France 24 en el que
los periodistas son los invitados y Con
quienes conversamos de una manera más
distensionada sobre algunos de los
hechos destacados de esta semana para
conversar sobre la selección de temas
que tenemos para este programa saludamos
a Fausto pretelli Muñoz él es editor de
la sección internacional de el
economista se conecta desde la Ciudad de
México Fausto Bienvenido al programa y
qué tal termina usted su semana gusto
saludarles Santiago pues muy
intempestiva muchas actividades muchas
noticias
y también desde la capital mexicana se
conecta a esta conversación Paloma Gómez
Pereira ella es internacionalista y
colaboradora de ADN 40 Paloma también
Bienvenida al programa y qué tal termina
la semana
mucho gusto muy contenta de estar aquí y
pues la verdad es que sí estuvo movida
pero sobre todo con temas muy
interesantes que estamos viendo en el
terreno internacional algunos de ellos
los vamos a estar tratando y conversando
aquí con ustedes en el programa y
finalmente aquí en el estudio de France
24 nos acompaña Laura Bonilla ella es
periodista y subdirectora de la
fundación pares para América Latina
Laura como siempre Un gusto tenerla aquí
en el programa Y cuéntenos qué tal
termina usted su semana es un gusto
estar aquí en Frank 24 otra vez y bueno
la semana acá en Colombia Movida en
temas nacionales y también en
internacionales todas las agendas se
están moviendo deportivas económicas
financiera internacional Pero bueno
acompáñanos también ustedes con sus
opiniones y sus comentarios y todas las
preguntas también son bienvenidas todas
a través de las redes ustedes ya las
conocen arroba
franz24_esántilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios numeral una semana en el
mundo f24 todo pegado todo junto para
que participen ustedes también a lo
largo del programa Pues esta semana se
lo contamos aquí en France 24 y también
lo analizamos los 12 años del inicio de
la guerra en Siria un conflicto que ha
dejado más de 600.000 fallecidos más de
7 millones de personas refugiadas y
otros tantos de millones de ciudadanos
sirios desplazados internos si bien este
conflicto se ha ralentizado por decirlo
de alguna manera su intensidad ha bajado
la guerra sigue abierta y sigue siendo
una amenaza este factor de prolongarse
en el tiempo que eso preocupa mucho a la
comunidad internacional pero Siria sigue
siendo una pieza clave en el ajedrez
internacional ya lo comentaremos con
nuestros invitados así estemos enfocando
la atención en los últimos meses o en el
último año en la guerra Ucrania Siria
Sigue estando presente en ese ajedrez
comienzo entonces aquí en el estudio de
France 24 Laura una guerra que de la que
ya no estamos hablando mucho lo
comentaba yo con algunos de mis colegas
En la redacción de France 24 le estamos
dando mucha importancia a Ucrania pero
la guerra en Siria sigue latente y sigue
siendo muy importante en el escenario
internacional no Incluso si tu juntas
las dos o sea es decir lo que está
pasando en Ucrania con la guerra en
Ucrania con lo que está pasando en Siria
yo creo que hay dos cosas que son
importantes a nivel global primero que
ya ambas guerras están agrupando
tensiones similares es decir el mundo
está muchísimo más tenso hoy y además la
guerra en Siria también implica el
fracaso sistemático de los esfuerzos
internacionales por desescalar el
conflicto y si tú ves eso junto con lo
que pasó esta semana justamente
alrededor de la guerra en Ucrania el
tema con el presidente Putin que también
vamos a hablar hoy pues Sencillamente
vemos que estamos ante un momento de
escalamiento que como lo vemos en la
guerra en Siria cuando empezó en el 2011
No termina nada bien Después de 12 años
todo está además entrelazado viendo los
factores internacionales le doy la
palabra ahora a Fausto en Ciudad de
México y dejó a Paloma para el cierre de
esta primera ronda Fausto su impresión
de estos 12 años lo que deja esta guerra
en Siria un conflicto que se ha
ralentizado baja la intensidad pero se
mantiene
sí está cronificado sirio país de 22
millones de habitantes la mitad o está
refugiado desplazada y creo que de
alguna manera nos también no se vincula
a esa sueño idílico de la primavera
árabe que de lo de de primavera no quedó
nada prácticamente quedó una
constitución Sí en túnez pero en
realidad vemos hacia Egipto está
gobernando un un dictador vemos en Siria
un dictador vimos el vemos a Libia que
de alguna manera pues también es un
estado fallido creo que lo que también
nos tendría que sorprender es el el
acercamiento diplomático que ha tenido
con con Arenas Saudita y con Irán eso
puede ser una buena noticia en el
sentido de queitas y su niñitas se han
sentado en la misma mesa creo que esto
puede remover en Oriente próximo mucha
de las piezas geopolíticas en la región
de Siria y bueno vamos a ver qué va a
suceder en las próximas semanas pero ya
ya es de alguna manera cronificado esta
guerra y Paloma para el cierre de esta
primera ronda adelante su opinión sobre
sobre este conflicto está esta semana 12
años del conflicto en Siria
pues dos años de un conflicto que además
se acaba de de complicar muchísimo por
el tema de del terremoto que tuvimos
hace algunas semanas cuando de por sí la
situación ya era precaria para la gran
parte de la población más del 90% de la
población de Siria está en situación de
pobreza vemos una un tema como como el
terremoto que llega y cambia totalmente
la perspectiva pero a mí me daba creo
que para cerrar es muy importante
regresar a las personas las personas que
llevan doce años en el conflicto y como
cuando les llega este este terremoto y
Hay muchísimas más ruinas yo escuché
como la la declaración de de una de las
personas que estaban ahí en Siria y que
decían la única diferencia entre las
ruinas de la guerra y las ruinas del
terremoto es que unas ya tienen
plantitas ya tienen hierbas que les
crecen no es la la única forma en la que
podemos diferenciar una de otras y
realmente es una una población que ya
normalizado esta situación y que están
muy acostumbrados a vivir en guerra Y
pues sí tristemente sin sin por lo menos
que les haya reportado algún beneficio
después de doce años de lucha no
lamentable la situación para los
ciudadanos sirios paloma continuó con
usted porque también una de las alertas
que nos llegó a lo largo de esta semana
fue acordarnos que hay millones de
personas en Siria que viven gracias a la
ayuda humanitaria internacional Pese a
que el conflicto pues ya no tiene la
prioridad por lo menos en los medios de
comunicación la atención ha estado
enfocada en Ucrania y si algo ha hecho
el presidente bayar al azar Paloma e
Fausto y Laura a raíz del reciente
terremoto en Turquía y en Siria es
volver a tener un poco más de
visibilidad internacional esto logrará
beneficiar un poco a los sirios en esta
crisis que están viviendo a raíz del del
terremoto logrará Siria volver a tener
esa importancia como crisis
internacional por encima de Ucrania o a
la par de Ucrania usted como lo ve
Paloma Pues sí lo que observamos ahorita
es que precisamente los los países sobre
todo de la región como que están
empezando a aceptar esta realidad de que
vayan a la Sad no se va a ir a ningún
lado de que este personaje y esta
familia que lleva gobernando Siria desde
los años setenta pues no se van a ir y
que están como del lado incorrecto Tal
vez ellos de la historia porque en su
momento estuvieron en contra de su
régimen entonces va a ser muy complicado
normalizar las relaciones entre
bueno tenemos inconvenientes con la
conexión de Paloma vamos con Fausto para
hacer la ronda la inversa Fausto su
opinión sobre la posición que tiene el
presidente al asad en este momento y
cree usted usted comparte esa opinión de
algunos analistas de al azar ganó la
guerra a pesar de El caos que sigue
siendo Siria en este momento
bueno todo depende gana porque siga
atornillado al poder pierde por la
cantidad de muertos que ha tenido en su
país continúa la guerra Siria hay unos
territorios que no puede controlar
fachada del Azar Pero de alguna manera
es Aliado de Vladimir Putin Y de alguna
forma Pues bueno eso le da cierta
garantía o cierto seguro de que puede
llegar hasta a seguir en en el poder y
yo insistía yo yo insistiría con el tema
de china que está también ya acercándose
a esa región de Gran influencia y por lo
tanto el acercamiento con Irán puede ser
muy importante con los sunitas que
también pues son los enemigos
fundamentales también de allá de bachada
de la sal y aquí en el estudio France 24
Laura Pues mira no esa guerra no está
ganada te lo hice una colombiana con un
conflicto armado de 50 años interno esa
guerra no está ganada y si bien es
cierto que a las Ada digamos tiene el
apoyo de Putin tiene el apoyo de varios
países Pues también es cierto que por
ejemplo la postura de Estados Unidos y
de la alianza que lidera Estados Unidos
es bastante confuso Entonces por una
parte
que el presidente Trump dice cuando
estaba Trump dice no nosotros finalmente
no nos importa tanto si bachar a las app
se queda O se va pero poco después con
la utilización de armas químicas digamos
y todos estos sucesos Trump también
decide mentiras y fue la primera vez que
se lanzó un ataque directo desde los
Estados Unidos hacia Siria entonces esa
situación que hoy la siente tranquila
donde hoy puede tener aliados pues lo
que nos han enseñado los 12 años es que
puede cambiar de un momento a otro y
realmente el país está quedando muy solo
sobre la pregunta si es posible que
Siria vuelva a ser una crisis importante
desafortunadamente también mi respuesta
es no creo que lo hablamos el día del
terremoto y decía no va a pasar o sea
Turquía va a tener toda la atención y
realmente la posibilidad de que la ayuda
turca llegue efectivamente también a las
poblaciones sirias o que negocien los
corredores humanitarios o que eso puede
ayudar un poco al país pues tampoco se
materializó
Laura pero algo que decía paloma es que
justamente a raíz de esta crisis
reciente por el terremoto algunos países
de la región han empezado como a aceptar
esta verdad
casi quien puesta que el presidente al
azar Pues sigue ahí es quien gobierna
toca relacionarse con él dentro del
mundo árabe esto no le no significa que
le está dando visibilidad y le está
dando un poquito de peso al al tema
sirio probablemente pero es que también
esos mismos países han estado digamos
dependiendo de En qué lado se ubiquen
los Acuérdate que hay cuatro bloques de
apoyo internacional a diferentes países
a todo el mundo no quiere a ISIS digamos
hay una Estados Unidos dice bueno Y si
es más malo que pasar a la Sad pero
inmediatamente salga Isis de la ecuación
o si sale Isis de la ecuación a la Sad
vuelve a ser Digamos como el malo
principal ahí digamos a ojos de la
coalición liderada por Estados Unidos y
frente al mundo árabe pues ellos siempre
te van a jugar a dos bandas digamos
puede que sí pero también voy a mantener
o ciertas ayudas o ciertos
entrenamientos o ciertos
movimientos de armas porque no voy a
permitir digamos que la frontera me sea
más porosa de lo que me está haciendo y
pues porque finalmente digamos que el
país está literalmente en ruinas
Entonces tampoco va a adquirir una
importancia real no cuando tenemos todo
el foco puesto en Ucrania lo que sí va a
pasar y sí puede pasar es que quien está
jugando un rol que es muy curioso de
promover la mediación en esa zona es
China y es fundamental que es donde uno
se pregunta qué intereses puede tener
china en este escenario Paloma
bienvenida de nuevo
Paloma
Bueno le doy la palabra a Fausto
adelante
el gol de China el rol de China es
geopolítico es estar de alguna manera
con los enemigos Estados Unidos
los de alguna manera este vínculo que
tiene con con Rusia que ha sido
equidistante cierto en Consejo de
Seguridad ha sido equidistante en la
asamblea general de Naciones Unidas por
el tema de la guerra en Ucrania Pero de
alguna manera
china hay que revisar que ya tenía una
ruta crítica después de que desmanteló
la democracia en Hong Kong con miras
hacia la posible invasión a Taiwán
Ucrania viene a trastocar un poco esa
ruta crítica ese programa que tenía
cronológico pero no significa que lo
deje a un lado al contrario yo creo que
está aprovechando también esta este
conflicto Ucrania Rusia para de alguna
manera alinear a uno de sus principales
aliados como es Rusia y a someterlo en
algún momento dado si si así fuera
necesario se está moviendo mucho Asia
vemos a Japón Corea del Norte Corea del
Sur y yo creo que en ese sentido creo
que la geopolítica después de la Guerra
de Ucrania
alineando a los enemigos de Estados
Unidos
qué hay del papel de Rusia y le preguntó
Porque vemos a Rusia involucrada en esta
guerra de Siria ayudando a basar al azad
suministrando todo tipo de ayuda a todo
nivel para mantener hasta Aliado
histórico que viene desde la época de la
unión soviética pero vemos a Rusia
también implicado en la invasión a
Ucrania obviamente y vemos a Rusia
también en otro frente de una manera
distinta aquí jugando a país gestor de
paz que es la guerra en la gordo caravag
donde hay una atención latente en este
momento allí es como el país que sirve
de árbitro entre Armenia la región de
nagorno caravaca Y azerbaiyán son muchos
frentes en donde se está involucrando
Rusia qué tanto puede sostenerse esto en
el tiempo
sí agregaría África con el tema del
grupo Wagner claro
yo creo que la bueno los bienes son
escasos no es decir el armamento es
escaso eh De alguna forma quizás en
términos de relaciones públicas o de
aspectos mediáticos quiere el presidente
ruso seguir mostrando cierta fortaleza
estando en muchos frentes como cualquier
potencia pudiera tener sin embargo en la
realidad pues dice lo contrario es decir
está debilitado en una guerra que sí que
si bien es cierto Putin es el que tiene
la última palabra para terminarla pero
continúa y tiene la bomba atómica tiene
armamento importante Eso sí las tropas
las tropas Son son limitadas no y Paloma
para el cierre de este tema la presencia
de Rusia de China Quiero conocer su
opinión que ya lo habíamos preguntado
aquí a los otros invitados pero quiero
darle usted también la oportunidad de
contarnos su perspectiva
Sí pues creo que la presencia
precisamente de de Rusia en este
contexto del conflicto de la guerra en
Ucrania Pues realmente hace muy difícil
que vuelva a tener ese protagonismo la
guerra en Siria porque en este momento
no es una prioridad de ese país el que
el que se resuelva el conflicto creo que
es importante decir que pues sí hay
mucho conformismo ya tratar de hablar
con rayar al azar porque finalmente es
un conflicto que ya lleva dos años y que
además hay muchísimos refugiados y
muchísima gente que está tratando de ir
a otros países y que genera un problema
en los otros países entonces sobre todo
el tema de Rusia y el tema de la Unión
Europea en este momento no es su
prioridad pero sobre todo quieren calmar
un poco las aguas para que el problema
de la migración y el problema que genera
estos más de cinco millones de personas
que están viviendo en los países vecinos
ya no sea un problema mayor como fue por
ejemplo en dos mil quince No pues ya que
estamos hablando de Rusia quiero que
hablemos sobre esa atención que fue
incrementándose a lo largo de esta entre
Rusia justamente y Estados Unidos a raíz
de un incidente ocurrido en el mar Negro
recordemos los hechos más básicos un
dron o un avión no tripulado de Estados
Unidos estaba sobrevolando esta zona del
mar Negro según Washington sobre aguas
internacionales y fue interceptado por
un par de aviones Hoy 27 de la Fuerza
Aérea rusa que como ustedes ven en las
imágenes derramaron combustible sobre el
dron como una medida disuasoria y
finalmente fue derribado a este hecho
hay también que Añadir que recientemente
la Corte Penal Internacional emitió una
orden de detención contra el presidente
de Rusia Vladimir Putin desde Moscú se
rieron se burlaron de esta medida que
calificaron como nula y sin sentido el
expresidente ruso dimitriever comparó
esta medida con el papel higiénico lo
estoy citando a él no lo digo yo
comienzo aquí en el estudio Laura un
episodio que está escalando más rápido
de lo que debería estar escalando como
lo ve el mundo está escalando más rápido
que debiera estar escalando Y esto no va
a salir bien o sea es decir lo que me
sorprende mucho y también lo conecto con
el tema anterior es que cada vez son
menos los esfuerzos multilaterales por
lograr soluciones pacíficas y cada vez
son más los esfuerzos multilaterales por
hacer crecer el conflicto en el mundo
Entonces sinceramente esta orden de la
Corte Penal Internacional Pues por
supuesto No comparto las palabras de
mendev ni más faltaba pero es una orden
completamente vacía es decir a Putin le
importa lo mismo que nada tiene una
orden por un caso además que tampoco ha
sido un caso relevante para la corte
nunca vamos como es el tema de de sacar
unos niños de un país a otro país eso
nunca ha pasado se acogieron un caso
cualquiera y dijeron pongámosle una
orden al presidente Putin y pues
finalmente a Rusia no le va a importar
pero si escala la atención en el mundo y
si pone a jugar también a Rusia frente
nuestros aliados o sea lo pone a jugar
también en un rol que para putines
fantásticos O sea me están persiguiendo
porque yo soy la alternativa a los
Estados Unidos y me están persiguiendo
porque yo soy la alternativa y todo el
discurso antiimperialista Incluso en
América Latina la guerra mediática puede
empezar a ganar la Putin con este tipo
de acciones claro además que vemos que
entre los dos países a raíz del
incidente del dron hubo comunicación a
nivel diplomático entre las embajadas
Moscú y Washington dialogaron
cordialmente y luego llega este otro
episodio que vuelve a tensar la relación
Laura su opinión sobre este tema
Perdón Paloma Perdón
Pues sí precisamente como bien dice
Laura o sea como que todo el tiempo
estamos viendo como de todos los lados
están subiendo la atención y están
tratando todos de mejorar como su
posición dentro de la narrativa misma de
la guerra no pero el problema que tiene
la guerra de Rusia contra Ucrania y esta
este juego al que juegan los los
miembros de la otan especialmente
Estados Unidos de nosotros le damos
armamento y estamos ahí vigilando y
estamos ayudando pero no estamos
directamente confrontados contigo
estamos empezando a ver sus limitaciones
Por qué Porque en cualquier momento eso
puede convertirse en una confrontación
directa Y eso qué significaría eso se
volvería realmente algo grave porque
pues finalmente ya mentoríamos a una
cantidad de países con un Arsenal
militar muy importante a una guerra que
en estos momentos no es suya no y
hablando también de del tema de la Corte
Penal Internacional bien lo dice Laura
es muy difícil
como esta este juicio a sobre todo a
presidentes que están además en
funciones Y ya y le ponen un caso que
además pues no es muy emblemático porque
porque es muy difícil de comprobar este
tipo de delitos y sobre todo cuando tú
como país no reconoces La autoridad de
la Corte Penal Internacional firmaron el
estatuto de Roma en el 2000 pero nunca
lo ratificaron entonces realmente no
tienen un compromiso con la Corte Penal
Internacional y lo que observamos es que
lo único que hacemos con este tipo de
acciones si bien es tratar de hacer que
rinda cuentas el gobierno de Moscú Pues
también un poco lo aislamos de todo este
sistema de reglas y todo este sistema de
normas y de derecho internacional con el
que jugaba el mundo pues hace algunos
años por lo menos antes de la de
conflicto con Ucrania es que uno puede
entender la carcajada en el kremlin no
sé si usted está de acuerdo Fausto
cuando haya un organismo internacional
que uno tiene jurisdicción en las
fronteras de su país pues qué es lo que
está tratando de hacer el mundo
occidental o la Unión Europea o la corte
Ucrania
Quien entiende esto
bueno Es evidente que en la guerra la
primera víctima es la información
esto de alguna manera pues sirve mucho
para para
activar las redacciones de los medios de
comunicación los periódicos pero en
realidad pues los efectos que pueden ser
o pueden tener con Rusia es un como una
especie de pellizco de de monja no es
decir no les va a hacer caso y también
Santiago creo que también es importante
Ya mucho la atención en términos
tecnológicos como los drones están
cobrando mucha importancia a veces ya se
da por hecho que la tecnología está
presente pero Estados Unidos informó que
ya había desactivado toda la información
que había recopilado y en ese sentido yo
recuerdo muy bien a finales de noviembre
el Primer Ministro de Japón dijo que
Japón tenía que dejar la ciencia ficción
para entrar a una realidad la realidad
de China y aquí cuando usted mencionaba
el tema precisamente de esta colisión o
más bien que colisión pues este derribo
del dron por parte de un de un avión
militar ruso habla precisamente de
primero involucramiento que quiere tener
Rusia sobre Estados Unidos decía un cara
a cara Más allá de que esté con Ucrania
batallando en el campo de de tierra
pero la tecnología no deja de llamar
mucha atención habíamos visto estos
drones que utilizaba Israel en contra de
algunos palestinos que son muy
focalizados pero pero creo que no hay
que dejarlo atrás el tema de los drones
está muy presente le son Guerras
asimétricas en muchas ocasiones
híbridas donde quizás no se no tiene un
impacto masivo de daño pero sí
estratégico no me quedo con lo del
pellizco de monja claramente nunca antes
Mejor dicho Laura pero Fausto continuó
con usted porque usted dice algo
importante dice este tema tecnológico a
mí la sensación que me dejó este
incidente sobre el mar Negro y este dron
de Estados Unidos es que Estados Unidos
está más cerca de la guerra y más cerca
de la línea de combate de lo que
pensábamos porque siempre se mostraba
desde el otro lado del Atlántico
enviando tone de dinero a Ucrania para
invertir en armamento tratando de
empujar a los europeos para que enviaran
tanques aviones y Arsenal pero Estados
Unidos está ahí Eso es lo que nos deja
esa sensación no sé si ustedes la
comparten Fausto Sí sí está ahí está
presente con otan está presente con
entrega de armas y ocurre este este
incidente cuando Polonia decide entregar
aviones a Ucrania es decir las líneas
rojas que pensábamos hace un año que
existirían y que no se iban a romper
pues está rompiendo se está rompiendo el
techo eh de manera progresiva se está
escalando y la pregunta es si Alemania
en algún momento dado en los próximos
doce meses va a entregar aviones o no a
Ucrania y ya prácticamente pues ahí sí
Tener razón el presidente de Rusia no es
decir la otan está presente no solamente
con decisiones importantes de
información de inteligencia sino también
con armas y sobre todo con armas muy
importantes como puede ser casas No
claro y ya al lado de la frontera
Finlandia está a punto de entrar Laura
para el cierre de este tema Pues mira
Fausto decía algo que me llamó mucho la
atención y que creo que tiene todas las
razones que los gobiernos europeos están
jugando al mismo tiempo una agenda doble
Entonces una agenda doméstica donde
están tratando de hacer que sus
ciudadanos estén muy indignados con la
guerra en Ucrania sobre todo con
gobiernos Pues tintecito un poco más
populista como lo que pasó en Suecia
también al mismo tiempo que intentan
mantener el balance internacional y esas
dos cosas no son compatibles O sea tú no
puedes poner una política local
completamente efervescente crear unos
perros de pelea ahí y después decir
Bueno pero quiero mantener el balance
ahora mantener el balance no te da
réditos mira que hagamos la posición del
presidente vay de nacido bueno como
recuperamos el balance de la otan cómo
hacemos que esta política militar
disuasoria vuelva a funcionar o vuelva a
tener el mundo tranquilo y con sus
propios ciudadanos no funciona Entonces
si uno hace en cambio a Putin le
funciona muy bien o sea Putin es el mago
de la indignación y es el mago de fácil
él puede prácticamente incendiar zonas
de su país para que lo apoyen
fervorosamente o en base a cierto
nacionalismo y no Europa tratando de
jugar a lo mismo es muy mala idea porque
efectivamente puede pasar lo que desean
Paloma y Fausto Qué pasa si Alemania
empieza a escalar ahora también esto y a
mandar más armas y más aviones sí es un
es un escenario
interesante el que usted plantea Paloma
para ir cerrando este tema para avanzar
con los otros temas que tenemos para el
programa sienten ustedes que estas
medidas y lo que ha ocurrido a lo largo
de esta semana es porque occidente está
en cierta forma Paloma perdiendo un poco
terreno Está tratando de acorralar a
Rusia en este momento de la guerra La
balanza se está inclinando hacia el lado
ruso
bueno se nos vuelve a desconectar paloma
en este momento retomo Entonces la
conexión con Fausto adelante Ah bueno
Ahí está paloma con nosotros otra vez me
confirman Ahí está sí adelante Paloma
qué desastre esto Una disculpa pero
bueno un poco lo que decía es que
realmente para poder tomar cualquier
paso hacia algún acuerdo
hay más partes están buscando mejores
posiciones desde las cuales negociar y
creo que esta escalada responde un poco
a eso que es muy peligrosa yo creo que
sí pero creo que es una estrategia para
poder presionar de parte de los dos
lados y decir Bueno vamos a a negociar
claro la negociación la busca la Unión
Europea la voz que Estados Unidos que
son a los que no les conviene seguir
alargando esto porque tanto Rusia como
Ucrania todavía no están conformes con
lo que tienen y no están conformes con
lo que podrían conseguir en un acuerdo
de paz pero realmente esta escalada de
parte de Unión Europea y de Estados
Unidos yo sí la veo como un poquito para
presionar a Rusia y decirle no vas a
lograr todo lo que vas a lograr y mejor
Siéntate a negociar y Fausto para el
cierre rápidamente para el cierre de
este tema
bueno en la guerra la está perdiendo
Ucrania Porque existe el peligro de que
sigan los muertos desde ese punto de
vista no estoy hablando desde el punto
de vista del número de bajas que pues no
se conocen con certeza o la realidad no
nos dice también podríamos decir que
Rusia está perdiendo territorio de la
que del que ganó al inicio de la guerra
sin embargo el miedo al terror La
paranoia y la inseguridad la tienen en
este momento los ucranianos y por lo
tanto la Sigue perdiendo las grandes
Víctimas de este conflicto Pues seguimos
hablando de tensión a lo largo de esta
semana y esa atención también fue en
aumento y se mantiene en su punto máximo
en Francia a raíz de la decisión del
presidente Manuel macú y aprobar la
reforma al sistema de pensiones a través
del artículo 39:3 sin pasar por el
debate en la asamblea nacional la
decisión por supuesto No cayó bien entre
los bloques de la oposición tampoco en
algunos sectores de la sociedad francesa
y por supuesto No cayó nada bien entre
los sindicatos con los que el presidente
evitó dialogar y concertar las calles de
diferentes ciudades francesas fueron el
escenario de manifestaciones que
terminaron en algunos casos en choques
con la policía hay más de un centenar de
personas detenidas después de las de los
hechos de violencia que se registraron
por ejemplo en el centro de París en las
imágenes que ustedes están viendo en
este momento ahora la oposición presentó
entonces una moción de censura esto es
un punto de quiebre para el gobierno del
presidente Mako y muchos se preguntan
Mako hizo lo que debía hacer o hizo lo
que quería hacer le preguntó a Fausto
hizo lo que quiso hacer es decir ya su
segundo gobierno no va a haber una
reelección de su parte yo creo que sería
difícil
que pensar en este momento macron sobre
su popularidad que va a caer
evidentemente segundo Es una muy buena
noticia que este tipo de decretazos eh
de alguna manera se tomen sin la base
democrática de la asamblea que es muy
importante tercer elemento creo que el
partido socialista francés pues tiene la
oportunidad para ir ganándole terreno y
prepararse pronto para pues algunos
movimientos o algunas elecciones cuando
cuando lleguen no fortalecerse y bueno
la izquierda radical pues lógicamente es
la que más va a ganar y también hay que
decirlo marile pen es decir el otro
extremo del espectro político eh estas
decisiones evidentemente drenan la
popularidad de El gobernante en este
momento pero también hay que decir que
son varios presidentes ahí en Francia
los que han intentado sacar esta
política no lo lograron este se vincula
más a una realidad a una tensa realidad
en donde la medicina ha avanzado y
quizás hay que repensar un poco la edad
evidentemente de cuando uno se debe de
retirar no Paloma su opinión aquí esto
es un triunfo del presidente Mako o esto
le va a pasar factura porque esta moción
de censura por parte de la oposición
haciendo cálculos sumas restas con todas
las la lo que se puede gestar allí en el
parlamento no le da los números para que
esta moción prospere
yo si lo veo precisamente como un golpe
al presidente macrón que ha estado
luchando muchísimo con esta reforma de
las pensiones y coincido por un lado con
con Fausto cuando dice él hizo lo que
quiso hacer Sí pero porque estaba
obligado a hacer algo qué eso fue lo que
él decidió decidió o sea él estaba
obligado a mantener el equilibrio
financiero de Francia a miras de dos mil
treinta como bien dice Fausto porque la
gente está envejeciendo y dura muchísimo
más tiempo vive muchísimo más la la
digamos la esperanza de vida es
muchísimo más alta y algo se tenía que
hacer para poder mantener el equilibrio
financiero del país y además para que
esto no fuera un problema en unos cinco
diez años algo se tenía que hacer y de
ahí de entre las opciones que tenía que
la verdad ninguno era muy buena ni
ninguna era muy popular pues Emmanuel
macron decidió esta estas legislación Yo
creo que él calculaba que le iban a dar
los votos en el parlamento finalmente
tal vez no dimensionó la cantidad y la
fuerza con la que iban a venir las
protestas Y cómo grupos iban a decir yo
no me voy a comprar esta crisis política
yo no yo no quiero este costo político y
lo abandonaron porque yo creo que el
verdaderamente sentía que tenía los
votos en el parlamento Y ahorita está
viviendo su momento más frágil dentro de
sus dos gobiernos y precisamente
abriéndole la entrada a estos extremos
que ya estuvieron a punto de ganar la
vez pasada pero que tampoco están bien
cohesionados de cara un un escenario
electoral para el futuro lo que dice el
gobierno es que un no hacer una reforma
del sistema de pensiones le costaría el
estado Francia hace unos 12.500 millones
de euros más tardar en el 2030 si no
hacen la reforma el descalabro sería
impresionante el aura Sí pero la pudo
haber pasado por la asamblea es decir
siempre hay necesidades de hacer
reformas Y por supuesto cuando las
sociedades cambian se necesitan reformar
pero primero subir la edad de pensión
así digamos a pupitrazo limpio no es la
única reforma que se requiere con un
sistema de pensiones y segundo el mundo
y especialmente Europa ha avanzado en
muchísimas opciones del mundo pensional
Entonces sí realmente yo creo que macrón
intentó también para subir su
popularidad digamos en plena crisis
política intentar acercarse más hacia la
derecha y hacerse ver como el hombre
fuerte que no va a ceder en esto que ya
lo ha hecho en otras ocasiones pero
tampoco tiene ni la popularidad ni la
legitimidad ni el apoyo suficiente ni
dentro de la asamblea ni en la calle
para mandarse con vamos con una medida
de este tipo entonces creo que fue muy
mal cálculo y le va a salir muy mal le
va a salir muy mal y eso lo está viendo
ya la gente en las calles veíamos las
imágenes de las manifestaciones en París
han convocado a nuevas manifestaciones
esto Laura es un punto de quiebre en esa
relación he estado sociedad es un punto
de no retorno en ese descontento con el
que ya venían los franceses hay un
descontento con el presidente macron
desde el primer periodo presidencial
votaron por él en contra de no a favor
de él Entonces esto
va a ir también una atención en aumento
escalando Claro pues pero pero digamos
que el cobro va a ser hacia la centro
derecha y en este caso lo más probable
es que eso ese descontento lo capitalice
la izquierda Me le echó o lo capitalice
la pen pero más la izquierda digamos la
gente va a intentar decir bueno Cuál es
la opción política que me protege a mí
mis derechos laborales y mis derechos
pensionales finalmente nadie quiere
excepto los suecos trabajar hasta los 75
años Claro porque tiene unas condiciones
muy particulares que no las tienen
incluso otros países de Europa los
suecos viven en una pequeña burbuja
digámoslo así Fausto su opinión sobre
sobre este tema de lo que le puede
representar al presidente Majo a futuro
y a Francia como tal la democracia y esa
relación con los sindicatos que en esta
negociación no fueron tenidos en cuenta
Sí ese pierde legitimidad evidentemente
la figura del presidente macrón Ese es
Claro que los equilibrios entre las
finanzas públicas sanas y lo que decían
los sindicatos y la sociedad a veces
cuesta mucho y hay que ceder
precisamente puntos en las encuestas
Pero insisto yo creo que esa es una
oportunidad para la oposición y sobre
todo marine le pen que ahora sí Ahora sí
podría estar escalando de manera muy
grave
pronto no en las elecciones
presidenciales pero es macrón yo creo
que los la cultura francesa es muy
paternalista Y si vemos este política de
pensiones desde América Latina cuando
México son 65 años de la jubilación
etcétera pues habla mucho de que hay
mucha
mucha terciopelamiento allá en en
Francia no mucha comodidad pero vivimos
mundos distintos diferentes pero a ver
qué sucede no son realidades diferentes
llego ya al final del programa me queda
un minuto para cerrar quiero
preguntarles a Qué temas van a estar
ustedes haciendo revisión a lo largo de
la otra semana o que tienen ustedes en
mente porque va a tener resonancia a
nivel internacional comienzo por Paloma
en Ciudad de México
Pues yo le voy a estar echando muchísimo
ojo
a todo el tema de las políticas que está
proponiendo en temas de migratorios en
el Reino Unido y como este como
reconfiguramiento del Reino Unido
también la presentación de su
presupuesto la presentación de este mini
presupuesto que que presentó esta semana
y cómo lo recibe digamos la gente porque
realmente Reino Unido es un personaje es
un actor importantísimo a nivel
internacional y ahorita se ha vuelto
Pues un enanito no entonces creo que el
regreso de la estabilidad en en Reino
Unido es uno de los temas que voy a
estar siguiendo rápidamente Fausto sus
temas Bueno el martes seguramente va a
ser interesante Japón porque van a
liberar van a anunciar que van a liberar
agua contaminada Esto va a generar mucha
controversia a nivel internacional y
vamos a ver en términos científicos Qué
características va a reproducir este
impacto y segundo creo que hay que
seguir la ruta crítica de Rusia Estados
Unidos con la caída del dron porque este
es una historia larga Sí y rápidamente
Laura Aquí muy puntual Pues mira yo le
voy a hacer seguimiento a una noticia
esta semana que íbamos a conversar hoy
que no nos dio el tiempo que es justo el
tema de china en América Latina la
expansión de china en América Latina y
en África me parece que es de los
temazos de la otra semana y nos da para
un poquito más a raíz de ese
establecimiento de relaciones con
Honduras y que pobre Taiwán claro se
queda sin apoyo internacional a los tres
les agradezco muchísimo haber estado con
nosotros en el programa me despido
rapidísimo que se me acaba el tiempo
Gracias a ustedes por la sintonía sigan
con nosotros
[Música]